okay so Ant-Man and there was quantum
Mania is now out and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the film talking about some of the
Easter eggs the ending and also Erica be
going in the future this review is gonna
contain Jonathan Major Spoilers so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
then I highly recommend you check out
now if you enjoy the video please smash
the thumbs up button and if you want to
support the channel we've just launched
the size Matters Ant-Man inspired
t-shirt which will be linked as the pin
comment now speaking of pushing terrible
merch after a little scene with Jenna
and Kang we will join Scott Lang who's
now everywhere due to the celebrity that
he gained after saving the universe
thank you Spider-Man
he's reading look out for the little guy
at book events he's the employee of the
century he's running the red carpet and
this ant is now upping the ante like
he's your uncle
we've got the theme from Welcome Back
Kara he's doing sleight of hand with
Jimmy woo hope has made pimtech back to
being a big name it's the perfect life
welcome back however he and his daughter
Cassie on as close as they used to be
he's now so wrapped up in the attention
that he's taken his attention off his
daughter and he's now following in his
footsteps she gets arrested for taking
part in a peaceful protest for homeless
people and this is of course reflecting
the thief with a heart of gold that
Scott was in the first film and we
discovered that lots of people lost
their home during the blip and that not
many people can afford to pay rent now
while Scott is living the high life they
do kind of use this idea of helping the
town and out to foreshadow a rebellion
storyline later on that we'll talk about
more as we get into the video Scott told
Arc in the movie is basically that he
saved the universe once but that he does
nothing now I was kind to thinking with
time dilation in the quantum realm that
they might return to earth years in the
future and see it decimated but there's
no real Stakes to this movie and the
pims have also been mentoring Cassie too
and along with gaining a suit she's also
been looking into the quantum realm
Scott is everywhere though infatuated
with himself and you can't even get in
the car with a guy without hearing his
audiobook playing on the radio which to
be fair I do listen to my own videos
sometimes see a chump he tries to guide
her as well as he could but he
constantly falls back to bragging about
meeting Rocket Raccoon and also being
friends with the Hulk anyway we discover
that Cassie's build a sort of telescope
that looks into the quantum realm and
after the family is sucked into it the
plot kicks it up a notch you could say
it's up in the ante like your uncle a
that's why we made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
we can help each other with that
[Music]
you know what down here we meet several
new characters including the societies
that Kang's already conquered Scott and
cassia taken to a group of runaways I
lost their home to Kang and we even get
a little Cameo by David Das malchin
who's playing a new character down in
the quantum realm now Janet Hank and
Hope come across krylar who possibly had
a fling with Janet whilst she was down
there and his character has some brief
ties to the comics krylar appeared in
The Incredible Hulk issue 156 and he was
someone that lived in the microbase he
was killed in the same issue that he was
introduced in so there's not that much
history in the source material but I
appreciate the little nod to this more
obscure character either way he now
answers to Kang and you can tell that he
blames Jennifer fleeing so that they had
to fight him alone they steal his ship
and though you might feel bad that
kreiler hit it Hank wasn't hanking every
night as we learn he slept with a woman
named Linda nice anyway Kang's forces
arrive with Murdoch and the B guy takes
them prisoner Murdoch is a big changer
from the comics in the mechanized
organism designed only for killing has
yeah that's his name has now been
reworked so that is Darren cross
defeated at the end of the first Emma
movie his body was distorted due to his
suit malfunctioning after Scott broke it
he commands the pythians in this early
attack and these villains pull directly
from the comics and were what made up
Kang's Legion now he's trapped in a CGI
body that makes him have T-Rex arms a
little cute butt and a massive head kind
of feel sorry for the guy who had to
work on this the CGI artist has actually
know someone who worked on cat I feel
like they wake up every day completely
embarrassed about what their life turned
into
now the comics had him being George
Tarleton genetically mutated in order to
grow his brain and this proved too big
for his body there's lots of different
takes on the character in the comics and
I actually think that this is probably
gonna be one of the most divisive things
Marvel's ever done it's such a big swing
and I think a lot of people are gonna
hate it but there'll also be some that
find this as another weird and wacky
thing for the movie personally I think
the character was best depicted in The
Avengers game and unfortunately seeing
it done so well there makes us feel like
a misfire now it's also during this time
that we meet Kang in case you don't know
Nathaniel Richards was born in the 30th
century and he lived in a
technologically advanced Utopia that
flourished for years and years his
backstory has been changed up several
times over the decades without being new
incarnations that play with the
structure however there is one key theme
going through them all Richards got
bored with how perfect his life was and
he decided to travel back in time now
some versions had him instantly becoming
a conqueror in the past and in many
instances he travel back to ancient
Egypt here he became Rama turd who we
meet at the end of the movie and this
pharaoh ruled over the ancient Society
for several decades however when the
Fantastic Four would displaced from time
they ended up taking him down and thus
he flared in the time stream once more
knowing Kang owning myself left to
conquer we watch as Nathaniel went back
in time and encountered an elderly
version of himself who brutally trained
him the young Nathaniel was in his iron
lad guys and wanting to do good he vowed
to take out his older self after he
killed one of the many forms of ravono
Ren Slayer that he'd ended up falling in
love with this threw him into a time
traveling war against many versions of
himself and he encountered several of
the incarnations of Kang along with
reincarnations of rivona in the end War
destroyed him and he ended up becoming
the very thing that he saw to take out
as a bitter old man he encountered his
younger version that the comic book
started off with then the cycle once
more repeated it's an incredible story
that I definitely recommend you pick up
as it explores the tragic backstory of
Kang whilst also showing just how much
of a threat he is now in the movie we
learned that the version of can we
encounter is known as the Exile and that
he was cast out from the Council of
kangs he even talked about getting
revenge on those who banished him and
it's clear that he was too and yieldy to
be amongst them I would take my revenge
on those who banished me one of the most
dangerous incarnations he's an
incredible threat that gets beaten in
his first movie by Ant-Man in the WASP
however we do get some of his past
touched upon and we learn that at the
very least that this is a Kang who
managed to kill a Thor variant now we
meet this version in the opening scene
of the film when we catch Janet stuck in
the quantum realm she sees a ship come
crashing down and weird Quantum realm
creatures end up attacking her and Kang
saves the day throughout the film we
learn what went on with a pair and why
she's so terrified of traveling into the
quantum realm now I kinda saw this as a
bit of a plot hole because at the end of
the last Ant-Man film we watched as she
was happy sending Scott down there but
here she's basically like Jamie Lee
Curtis in Halloween still though
Michelle Pfeiffer gives an incred
incredible performance and to me she's
definitely one of the strongest members
of the cast
[Music]
let me make this easy
either way we discover that Kang had a
ship which could travel a Multiverse and
that he and Jenna attempted to fix it he
promised to help her get her time back
with her but she learned of his true
nature via a neural network that she
connected to on the ship and for me it's
the best scene in the movie and I kind
of wish the entire film was like this
we've seen flashbacks he destroyed
worlds and entire timelines across space
it's possible that he who remains is
somewhat a variant of him as we know
that he too likely had to do this in
order to create the sacred timeline that
we see in Loki season 1. at one point he
talks about how he knows what's coming
at the end and he also sets up just how
dangerous the council is they eventually
cause endless incursions which leads to
a multiversal war that we've of course
had teasers towards already feel like we
should have started Phase 5 with a solo
Kang movie that showed this and we could
have followed him destroying worlds
before getting exiled at the quantum
realm after confronting him about it
Janna ended up stealing the drive and
[__] with it which left him trapped
down there however she'd given Kang
enough power to at the very least get
his super back thus he started
Conquering the quantum realm Janna ended
up running away and she feels like she
left everyone down there to live in a
press life although she shouldn't feel
guilty this is sort of the case too
since then kangs used his telekinetic
powers to dominate and now everyone
fears him it's a shame because they set
him up as being a massive threat but
Kang forgets to use those powers in the
final battle even though he could have
mopped the floor with Scott instead he
relies too much on his army and Blasting
people and we get to buy the numbers
fight scene that most Marvel movies tend
to evolve into for example you had shuri
vs no more on the beach which I thought
was good but they also had to have the
dumb stuff on the boat we also had the
father versus son fighting chongqi but
then there was the dumb under dweller
thing happening on the island kinda hope
the movies move away from this as the
best finales for me don't involve this
sort of thing a Kang holds Cassie
hostage and Promises to kill her in
front of him and loop the moment so that
Scott has to witness her death over and
over again for eternity it's a really
chilling moment and and all that Scott
has to do to stop this is go and help
him as he sets out on a quest to get the
device Kang needs in order to repair his
ship this includes traveling into the
multiversal engine that contains a
probability storm in which every moment
creates a different branched moment as
they say in the film this is
Schrodinger's box and he's the cat you
watch him split out and even get a
Baskins in Robin's guy going under the
name Jack like he was in the first movie
this was actually a reference to Paul
Rudd's real life son who is also called
Jack those that get near to the device
end up dying however when they focus
their thoughts on saving Cassie they all
come together they build a giant ant
hill or a giant Hill or a small antel
really because it's in the quantum realm
anyway he falls into the pile after
failing to shrink the device which is
when he's saved by Deus Ex wasp this is
her entire character in the movie just
showing up at the last second and for
someone whose names in the title she
doesn't really get to do much eventually
they shrink it oh Jenna arrives and
Monarch attacks Hank on the ship calling
back to that old rivalry speaking of
rivalries Kang hints towards the council
and the others that banished him the
council itself is made up of several
members including ramatut immortus and
another version in our video yesterday
we talked solely about the two
post-credits scenes and in those we said
the third member was possibly the
Scarlet Centurion due to his name
appearing in the leaks these turned out
to be pretty accurate however I have
spoken to people behind the scenes
who've said this is actually iron lad
it's possible it's also a new creation
for the film and there is the chance
that he's the beyond the version who is
rumored will be appearing as the villain
in secret Wars and the car makes the
three main versions were known as the
trio of kangs and they made the majority
of decisions for the rest of the council
they were headed up by Morris who we too
see in this scene he's the oldest
version of Kang and most that live long
enough end up becoming him in the comics
he actually had a master plan to take
out the rest of the kangs and he created
the council to bring them all together
so that he could destroy them in the
source material namely The Avengers
forever storyline and kangana mortis
were juking it out through time and I
think this is what the multiversal MCU
War may lead to immortus manipulating
fighting within the council and in the
end all that was left was a character
known as Prime Kang Immortal sends
stepped forward and reveal that he
wanted to become the ruler of all time
and this could lead into him becoming he
who remains in the MCU now in the end
the kangs are happy that the Exile is
being killed but there's also the
possibility that he was just sent
further into the quantum realm either
way they believe that the heroes of the
MCU are getting closer to stopping them
and that they have to be taken out so
that they can rule over the Multiverse I
think this will be where Kang Dynasty
takes us too with a council ruling over
everything before the Kang in fighting
leads to a civil war between them taking
place in secret Wars now we actually get
a direct nod to the comics in the final
shot with a Coliseum of Kang's cheering
this is actually ripping on their first
appearance and that happened in Avengers
issue 292. either way we know the
council is a big addition for the MCU
and from the Exile we know that there
are versions of Kang that want to
destroy it anyway Hank is saved by some
ants and we learned that someone brought
into the quantum realm when they first
went into it due time dilation they've
been down there for thousands of years
have grown really smart and now built a
whole Civilization now when being
escorted to a cell Cassie breaks free in
the classic cliche prisoner transport
Escape scene and she rescues some of the
rebels Kang puts out a broadcast but
Cassie hijaxis basically does the speech
from the end of Andor to tell everyone
to mount up Scott arrives and then an
attack is launched on Kang City Modoc is
beaten and may you need to stop being a
dick akang seems to be handling it all
pretty well until one thing arrives that
he didn't prepare for ads
[Music]
anyway they swarm him and Murdoch shows
up and says that he's not a dick finally
embracing his down cross side he breaks
Kang's shield and scary Kang away and
Murdoch dies saying that at least he's
an Avenger now which is he though at
this point they gotta leave but
kangarize once more he's trying to get
to Earth and Scott makes it his mission
to stop him from leaving even if it
means he has to lose it's Kang vs Lang
in a Kang bang that you can't hang mine
mang like Scarface hey [__] you man now
at this point hope arrives once more and
Saves the Day smacking him into the
multiversal engine the pair are
seemingly trapped down there and
according to the original leaks on the
film they were going to be stuck there
which would end the movie they were
pretty spot on for the other parts of
the film but it looks like something
changed along the way and Cassie uses a
device to open a doorway for them to
travel through earlier in the movie she
stated that if she had something like
that when he was gone that she could
have saved him and this is very much her
making sure that she doesn't lose her
dad at the end of the movie very much
brings the beginning full circle with
Scott once moderating his life he picks
up a birthday cake for Cassie and even
though it's not actually her birthday
he's making up for the ones he missed
made by his former Baskin and Robin's
boss Scott seems to be back on top but
something still plagues his mind Kang
promised that others were coming and
Scott fears that he's doomed the world
however they don't need to worry about
that right now it's a nice way to kill
all the stakes and we are with Scott
taking a bite out of the cake and
gagging was his boss really a Kang
variant is he dead no probably not but
it ends the movie on the idea that not
everything is sunshine and rainbows and
that this sweet ending has a better
aftertaste to it this is reflected in
the first power's credit scene which
we've already discussed and we get more
teases of Kang coming down the line in
the second here we catch Loki and Mobius
at a theater in the early 20th century
which is when we see a presentation by
the Kang Varian Victor timely in the
comics Kang ended up traveling back to
1901 after another Himalayan feet and
here he founded a town filled with
factories and businesses he build up the
town of timely Iran himself and even
became the mayor using his knowledge of
the future to build himself up the name
timely is also another timely as well as
before Marvel was Marvel it was Atlas
Comics and before that it was timely
comics big to build Androids and
duplicates of himself and he even took
of the name Victor timely Jr and
pretended to be his own son I'm in this
scene Loki is terrified of him razmobius
doesn't seem that bothered keep almost
saying morbius and I I've got that movie
locked in my brain cause such a good
film come on come on
however I do think it teases out what
the second season of Loki is going to be
about and I can't imagine it's gonna be
a buddy cop thing where the hunting down
Kang variants the first season was about
hunting down lucky and therefore that
makes the most sense to me in terms of
what could be happening now he also have
the fact that the Fantastic Four are
coming soon actually feel that they
might interact with the Council of kangs
at some point and this will be what
brings them out in the comics read
Richards actually ended up creating a
council of read to stop him and it's
possible that they're going to do
something similar in the MCU that's what
my thoughts on the movie I thought this
was the greatest film of all time Marvel
you've done it again shillium Shatner is
now back and after saying I was
disappointed with phase four I'm happy
to accept that Marvel money for positive
reviews
now being honest I think this film was
fine and that it's pretty much what
you'd expect from a middle of the road
Marvel movie made by committee it's just
one of those Adventures where things
happen and nothing really progresses and
we just have moments on the screen to
kill two hours now I don't think that it
deserves its rotten rating but I also
don't think it does anything memorable
or completely groundbreaking it feels
about as deep as a Targaryen gene pool
and there's so many things that are
badly handled in it which overrides the
actual good aspects firstly there's no
real Stakes to it and I really went in
this film thinking that Kang would win
however when he's beaten by Ant-Man it
doesn't make you feel like he's gonna be
the big threat that he should be I think
Jonathan Majors is the best part of this
movie but even then he doesn't feel like
he's as fearsome as he should be it was
the same problem that they had with Gore
and whereas the comics had a massacring
Gods across the cosmos the movie dumbed
it down to where we just heard about it
it's the same as what happened with Kang
and I think they should have actually
shown us some of the things that he did
rather than just telling us for example
you think about how Thanos was
introduced in Infinity war and we saw
him holding Thor hostage he kicked the
crap out of the Hulk and then kill Loki
just beating the strongest hero like
this instantly made him a threat and
throughout the movie we constantly
watched him winning you could also
emphasize with thanos's motives and
though you might not agree with them you
could at least see why he was doing what
he was doing Kang is just doing this
because he wants to rule and I hope they
reintroduce ravona soon so we at least
get some stuff we can gravitate towards
and Ball Road does as usual and you can
tell he's comfortable acting against the
greens screen however the others
especially Michael Douglas I just feel
like they didn't really get directed
properly and the environment in general
just feels very flat due to the real
lack of Direction there you compare this
to Avatar the way of water and that
feels like an actual immersive World
whereas this doesn't a lot of the time
this lack of weight is carried across to
the story as well with a feeling like
it's got the stakes of a Saturday
morning cartoon Murdoch is wasted and
everything's completely surface level
leading to this feeling like filler I
had this problem with a lot of phase 4
movies and it feels like they made it
for the sake of making it rather than
having a story that they needed to tell
even the post-creating with Canyon
concept is something that should be
massive what about Greg from real
Rejects and me were talking about it and
he said it was like an SNL sketch and I
couldn't get that out of my head when I
went and watched it now we always try
and fill my reviews with both good and
bad and it's actually weird going from
someone who gets called a Marvel shill
all the time to now being the biggest
hater of all time so as for the good
again Paul Rudd and the First Act of
this film works really well it's also of
course Jonathan majors and Michelle
Pfeiffer these feel like they're really
smashing it out of the park and I think
if and when they're given great material
that they're really Gonna Shine with
Kang Dynasty being worked on at the
moment I hope they look back at the
feedback from fans for this and realize
that they need to step it up a bit Mages
were so good and low-key and he
completely stole the show and based off
this performance as well I know he has
the potential to do it so in the end for
me this was a good way to start phase
five and I kind of hope they just stop
putting out so much content and instead
just focus on making the odd really good
thing like like they used to in the
olden days then just scaling stuff back
getting people involved with unique
ideas and moving away from this quantity
of a quality mind state that it's going
to help them massively a lot of the
problems of phase four haven't been
addressed here though and we'll see how
the rest of the site pans out as we get
into it feels like it's just a movie
setting about the movies rather than
being its own thing and I think that
these setup movies aren't good films
until years down the line once we know
they pay off now Marvel movies aren't
made to exist in a vacuum but I think
the best ones always work on their own
and hopefully this ends up getting
better with age of Ultron if you look
back at Phase One those movies all
worked on their own and they weren't
just put in place to be like well we're
gonna be doing something good down the
line just to waste two hours with us and
we'll we'll promise you it'll be good so
in summary Ant-Man in the WASP Quantum
Mania has its moments but overall it
misses the mark on a lot of things and
feels like the shell of a great movie
you can see the goodness in there but
it's just been stripped back to fit this
two hour run time unfortunately I wanted
to like it way more than I did and like
I said before there's that scene with
the two characters that I think really
should have been the tone of what the
whole movie was it's one of the best MCU
backstories we've ever had but
everything around it just feels so
middling I might like it more on a
second watch but I think it's
representative of the problem phase 4
had in that things are rushed to fit
that to our run time and the character
development suffers in favor of the
spectacle now you're completely free to
form your own opinion and if you haven't
seen the movie then I think you should
go and see it it's getting blasted
online at the moment and I think most
people will come out of it thinking it
wasn't as bad as everyone was saying and
that they might actually like some of it
I hope that's okay says there are often
moments and some of you might think it's
the best Marvel movie ever made it's got
some great jokes in it there are some
scenes with Kang that work really really
well however things like the whole Rebel
plot just completely forgettable to me
and it's very by the Numbers make up
your mind for yourself but for me this
gets a 6 out of 10. it's a very solid
six I'm not gonna put the five because I
think that would say it's a bad movie I
don't think it's bad I just don't think
it's as great as it could be now if you
have seen it then let me know your
thoughts below and I hope to see you on
the next video probably not probably
burned all my bridges with all my
hardcore MCU fans but I'm just giving my
honest opinion here and I'd rather do
that than be like oh it's amazing it's
the best movie ever and then five months
down the line be like oh we always told
you it was bad remember but the mcu's
getting better I feel like the fans need
to give honest critiques and that's the
only way that Marvel's gonna get better
it had such a good run we know they've
got it and they're yeah seeing them fall
off like this it is quite disheartening
so yeah let me know your thoughts below
and just to let you know we're giving
away three copies of the rocky 4K boxer
on the 15th of March all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film
repeat the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
post credit scene breakdown which goes
more in depth on those two final things
if not then thanks for sticking through
the video I'll be Paul you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care and bye [__] peace